all right it is here Bard is now Gemini
Google's smart assistant AI has been
updated big time when they unveiled
Gemini they showcased three versions
Nano for efficiency Pro that was added
to Bard that we could use for free and
Ultra the ultra was the Super
interesting part their paper discussed
that it is so good they think it might
even give gp4 a little competition and
and here comes the best part oh yes we
can try it for free right now so where
can we use it and what can it do let's
find out together dear fellow Scholars
this is 2minute papers with Dr car here
if you have an Android phone you can opt
in through Google assistant or download
the Gemini app and there you go and if
you have an iPhone it will come to the
Google app where you just hit a toggle
and it will be right there as of the
making of this video it was not
available for me but they announced that
it is coming in the next few weeks or
you can go to
gemini.com and just use it from the web
the regular Gemini is pretty smart and
remains free and Gemini Ultra is called
Gemini Advanced here and is available as
a paid subscription and there is a free
trial where all of you fellow scholar
can try it for two months and you also
get 2 terab of storage Google has some
advantages here as it can integrate with
your Gmail account can summarize your
messages and write emails on your behalf
it also has access to your Google Docs
slides sheets and get information and do
work on them it can also help you with
your coding can evaluate your ideas and
more it can do almost anything that you
would expect from a smart assistant that
works for you and it is going to be
right in your pocket all day almost all
around the world initial experiments
show that it can also estimate the
amount of calories from your lunchbox
label and so much more I also like that
it can try to verify the validity of its
statements from other sources this is a
feature that has existed before but now
I sometimes see it do it automatically
really nice love it and like open ai's
Dolly 3 this can also draw some
beautiful images for you too more
competition in that area as well it will
be hooked into your Google Assistant as
well making it so much smarter this is
also great because it will understand
the context from your previous messages
something that all major assistants
struggle with these days as far as I
understand Gemini is deployed to
230 countries and understands more than
40 languages according to their press
release Gemini Advanced is available in
150 countries and currently only speaks
English well I tried German Japanese and
more and they seem to have worked and
here comes the really cool part from the
earlier paper we saw plenty of
benchmarks that showed how amazingly
good the ultra is for more difficult
tasks like coding logic reasoning but we
could never try it ourselves and now we
can we can now rerun all of these
experiments and even run our own this is
heaven also competition against open AI
is heating up that is also excellent for
us the scholarly users I myself ran an
experiment from the USA Computing
Olympiad a task that they call insanely
difficult yes this is the one where you
have to assemble the robotic cows one of
my favorites this task requires a
technique called dynamic programming and
the size of the problem is huge so the
implementation has to be really
efficient to have even a fighting chance
to solve it this is something that gp4
was able to solve correctly so let's see
Gemini Ultra hm it starts in the right
direction but unfortunately not yet now
when gp4 arrived there was a huge
155 Page Long paper that subjected it to
every single test that you can imagine
and some that were really surprising
solving mazes mathematics playing text
based games drawing Maps writing a full
computer game and more and I am sure
that the same will happen to Gemini
Advanced as well and I cannot wait to
see them I Tred to look around and see
what you fellow scholar are up to and my
first impression seems to be is that gp4
likely Remains the smartest AI assistant
for now while Gemini will have the
advantage of being able to work within
Google's ecosystem and connect to your
other apps a little better so what
experiments did you run did it perform
well did it not is it As Good As It
Seems I'd love to know what you fellow
scholar are up to let's run some more
experiments and let me know in the
comments below how they went until the
new papers appear and they are coming
soon so we'll know so much more I am
really excited for this if you are too
make sure to subscribe and hit the Bell
icon to not miss out on them what a time
to be alive experiment tracking model
evaluation and produ ction monitoring
for your deep learning projects and llm
apps this is what weights and biases
does and it is the best everyone is
using it try it out now at wb. me/
papers or click the link in the
description below